صوته العذب واغانيه التي يغلب عليها طابع
الحزن كانت علامه فريقه في مسيرته الفنيه
الكبيره خلال السنوات الماضيه والحزن
الاكيد وغيرها من الاغنيات عذاب يصدقني من
الاغنيه التي ابدع فيها الفنان السعودي
خالد عبد الرحمن
ليكون رصيدا تاريخيا ساحرا في عالم
الموسيقى والغناء الخليجي النجم خالد عبد
الرحمن الذي ولد وترعرع في الرياض ابن
الاسره المتوسطه الحالي التي يعود اصلها
لبلده
[موسيقى]
الشاعر والفلاح خالد عبد الرحمن ضيفنا
اليوم في صباح العربيه
لحديثا اكثر رحابه عن تلك الطفوله والايام
الخوالي والجديد في عالم الفن والغناء
الذي يرجع فيه
نشات وترعرعت فيها
البيت الطين شوفوا حد للسور من هنا على
هناك
وعلى هنا على الزاويه على الزاويه تخيلوا
السورتين في هذا البيت هذه مدرستي
بالابتدائيه في بنبان
وانا عمري يمكن خمس ست سنوات
البركه هذه من الرياض ينورنا الفنان
القدير خالد عبد الرحمن اهلا بك فنان
الكبير ابو نايف
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بالخير جميعا وتحيه طيبه
للمشاهدين
[موسيقى]
لا والله بكل بساطه انا كنت طالع انا
وزوجتي نتمشى ومرينا منها المناطق فترى
عليه قلت بوريك وان كنت تدرس وين كان
اقامتي في هالمزرعه
[موسيقى]
منها الباب تصورت وتفاجات اي نعم بالوصول
لكم انها المقطع وصل لكم تحياتي الصراحه
للاهتمام من قبل الكميه تحياتي لكم
حياتنا لالك دوما ان احنا فخورين وسعداء
بوجودك معنا اليوم في صباح العربيه وعلى
شاشه العربيه فنان قدير من امثالك بنايف
اليوم بما انك عم تتحدث عن الاحاسيس
ومشاعر نوستالجيا خصوصا الفيديوهات اللي
انتشرت على السوشيال ميديا احد الكتاب
الفنيين في موقع العربيه نت قال بانه
بونايه يحتاج الى ان يعيش قصه حب حتى
يواصل تالق والتوحش انا اقتب التصريح سابق
لك في احد المقابلات انت تقول يا بني نايف
ما كنت تؤمن بالحب كنت استهزئ باللي يحبون
طيب كيف يمكن للفنان كله احاسيس ومشاعر
انه يستهزئ في الحب ويستهزء باللي بيحبوني
كيف
[موسيقى]
لا هي المقوله هذه جتك قبل لا يجي الفنان
وقبل لا يملكها المشاعر الاحاسيس
لان الموقف هو اللي صنع حال فنان
الحب
باختلاف انواع واشكاله سمه طيبه
انك تحب تحب
الاشياء الجميله تحب سليمه اللي تحب الناس
الطيبين للناس
الاسويه تحبي يعني في المحبه بالعكس وجوده
الجميع في حياه الانسان
اكيد طيب بنايه في اليوم لو كان معك عود
وهيك جاب بالك وانت موجود في هذا المكان
الذي عشت فيه وترعرعت وتعلمت واليوم يعني
كل شريط الحياه وسلسله الحياه والشريط
ذكرياتك كانت موجوده فيه معك العود اليوم
اي اغنيه بتخطر على بالك انك تغني لهذا
المكان وهذا الزمان
[موسيقى]
الموقف ولكن بحكم انه كان مرتبط بذاكر
الطفل ما في شيء من الاعمال اللي ممكن
يربطني في ذاكره الطفل اللي كان يعيش فيها
المكان ولكن لو سالتيني عن ذاكره الرجل
وفي مواقع اخرى مثلا همم ممكن اقول لك انه
في قصيده تتناسب
اتفضل
[موسيقى]
ما في بالي يعني اغنيه تتناسب مع ذاكره
الطفل اللي عاش هالمرحله يعني
اذا في مجال في هذا الصباح تعطينا هيك شوي
من صوتك الجميل
[موسيقى]
الله يسعدك ممكن
في كثير جماهير بتحب تسمع صدقيني الحب
يحكي لك حقيقه هذه القاعده اسمع موسيقى
الان
اوكي
[موسيقى]
قلبي يحكي لك حقيقه
صدقني ما ارى غيرك ملاك
ومن اجلي وصلك
ما ابالي لو طريقي لك هلالك
بعدك ولا غيابك على قلبي مطيقه كيف جاهد
روح
تشقى من غلاك
الشك من طبعك
وبحساسك رقيقه
مجبورتني سلامات
[موسيقى]
يا بني في اليوم في قله نخبويه ممنوصفون
تسلم قلنا نخبويه ممن يوصفون بالفنان
الشامل اليوم في عالمنا العربي عندما
نتحدث عن تلحين وكتابه الشعر وحتى الغناء
فما الذي جعل اليوم ابو نايف هو فنانه
شاملا
[موسيقى]
الظروف
حاولت انه
اقدم عماني لبعض الفنانين ولم تجد قبول في
البدايه وهم معذورين طبعا
لاني شخص غير معروف وكانت كتاباتي متواضعه
فتطور الامر الان تعلمت العود وغنيت اصبحت
اجيد الكتابه
[موسيقى]
فباذن الله
راح يكون
عن قريب باذن الله بالاسواق
بالتوفيق والفنانين دائما يبحثوا عن اسم
الشاعر قبل ان يبحثوا عن كلمات هذا الشعر
بالتالي من يسمع شعر
بدنا نسمع شعر خالد عبد الرحمن مباشره
يعني يغني ومغمض عيونه نفهم
[موسيقى]
الاسلوب
حتى لو قرئت له من لسان رجل اخر يعرف ان
هذا القصيده من من هذا الشعر فهو اسلوب
فكل شخصيه الشاعر له اسلوبه في الكتابه
طيب انا اكثر ما بحب لك يا ابو نايف وشلون
مغليك حياتي كلها لذه غرام فينا نسمعها
منك
[موسيقى]
وشلون مغليك
وانت الذي
علمتني احبك
يا هاجسي
عشقي يا
عيونك اسال وتقرا الجوال
في نظره عيوني
تصوير الاجمل عذاب بحبك يا مفتوري
وشلون
مغليك
وشلون مغليك
يا يا
عذب الصفات
يا كل الحياه
صبرك علي هذا قليل مهما ترى
من تضحيات
هذا قليل خلي السهر
لايون من حبك خلي العيون
اللي لها عشقت
السلام سلامتك
علي طيب بنايه في اليوم ما الذي بقي فيك
من جدران الطين الذي صورته في الفيديو
وهذا النخيل وهذه هي الحياه التي تناشدها
بالصبر عليك
لا تموت وتجدد عند زيارتها الاماكن هذه
وتبقى ذكر برده
مضحكه شويه انه اول مره اشوف الدم اا
اعزكم الله ينزل من انفي في المدرسه
كنت اجرب من خارج السور
وطفل ثاني يجري من خارج الثور من الجهه
الثانيه والتقينا في زاويه
فضربت خشمي في راسه في همم ارفمي نزل الدم
فهذه كانت اول مره اشوف دم ينزل منها وانا
طفل طبعا كان عمري في ست سنوات تقريبا
شفت المدرسه رجعت الذاكره
يعني نحنا لا يمل الحديث معك وللاسف انتهى
الوقت وكنا بنحب انه يكون فيه اكثر دقايق
ودقايق كل دقايق لا تكفيك شكرا جزيلا لك
وتحياتنا لك من فريق صباح العربيه